watch dogs too has been on my radar
since was announced this summer and
after sitting down with it for a couple
hours i'm happy to say that it's shaping
up to be the sequel we hope for this
time around you play as Marcus Holloway
a talented young hacker who grew up in
Oakland just east of San Francisco from
what I played players will be spending
most of their time in San Francisco but
the map extends from Marin up north all
the way down to Silicon Valley in the
demo we were asked to stay within San
Francisco but there was still plenty to
do and see the map isn't an exact
recreation of San Francisco but many of
the famous landmarks like Golden Gate
Bridge and the palace of the Fine Arts
have been meticulously recreated
but watch Docs to has more to offer than
a new setting for starters the hacking
is more robust while hacking in the
original game felt limited in contextual
watchdogs to gives the player a bevy of
options when you targeted NPC a hacking
menu appears and from there you can hack
it to the bank account you can set off
their phone to cause a distraction and
you can even have the cops arrest them
but phones aren't the only things you
can manipulate Marcus can also hack and
control cars or even set traps these
might seem like small features but being
able to use them to cause mayhem from
afar was incredibly rewarding
the improved hacking options also
translate well into the mission
structure open-ended missions are
nothing new but all the new hacking
abilities available to add another layer
of depth in one mission I had to break
into a fortified dock steal the truck
and drive it back to a dead sec base
getting to the truck was easy but
finding the code to the gate was locked
behind was another story I could have
gone my way through goons until I found
the guard with the code but I decided to
take a more stealthy approach using my
drone I surveyed the area until I found
a guard I could hack the digital keys
from and voila unfortunately my luck ran
out as I was trying to leave the dock a
guard spotted me in the chase hit the
streets fortunately the driving is
noticeably better and watchdogs to as
control is much more responsive maybe a
bit too responsible times but it's a
necessary change that lends itself to
the tight and narrow streets of San
Francisco in another mission I was
tasked with breaking into a heavily
secured mansion and once again I let my
robotic companions do most of the
legwork I only played a few missions
during my time of the game but watch
dogs too appears to embrace a level of
freedom not seen in the first that
encourages both creativity and
experimentation
you
911 please state your emergency
watch dogs two-story also feels like a
departure from the first Marcus Holloway
is a refreshing protagonist compared to
Aiden Pearce he is much more
lighthearted than the tone seems to
follow suit rather than being a lone
wolf type Marcus has a group of fellow
hackers he's constantly keeping in touch
with and working alongside wildly
supporting characters still need time to
grow on me hearing Marcus quit with them
is a welcome change compared to Aiden's
constant humorless brooding you've got a
weird relationship with technology you
know that right like Assassin's Creed
from last generation watchdogs to seems
to improve upon the first in nearly
every way with the quality of its
vibrant setting and expanded hacking
options it feels like watch dogs 2's on
the right path but we won't know for
sure until the game launches on November
15 for more on watch dogs to subscribe
to our YouTube channel and head on over
to gamespot com
you